alors ça c'est méchant benjamin tu es
méchant mais ça veut sourire on appelle
on appelle clément guérin pour venir
dans tpm paix que lorsque maxime dès 10h
à l'élevage où ma mère n'est pas dispo
c'est pas vrai parce qu'il vient tous
les mercredis maxime qui a dit ça vaudra
peut être aussi méchant
ouais c'est vrai que un jour on a appelé
maxime ils pouvaient pas celle ci
pouvait pas on a demandé à ma mère elle
pouvait pas et on sait magic cette
séquence
attention bien sûr vous fait pas les
mêmes qu'en civil via un invité qui l'a
adoré son film avec pouvait être sûr
qu'il ne l'a jamais pu dire ça des
collégiens je pense que c'est castaldi
c'est cher
vous avez raison c'est une honte eh bien
j'aimerais que parfois sur les pitchs
vous étiez très bon ouais et dès qu'il
fallait rentrer dans le détail
dans le détail des séquences et un tout
petit peu plus flou et si je peux me
permettre je m'engage ajouté vous êtes
meilleurs qu'on n'avait pas vu le film
c'est vrai parce que comme vous avez pu
vous donner des détails devraient sa
moye allemand devrait vous être meilleur
que vous avez pas vu ben merci beaucoup
[Rires]
et quand vous quand vous passerez autant
de cyril maxime aime tellement la magie
qu'il a disparu
[Applaudissements]
y aller salle et c'est un bon ami qui
salam aujourd'hui penser mais j'ai pas
dit mais c'est à dire que c'est drôle
j'arrivais à tpm pays on a mis tellement
plein la gueule quand même maxime
n'était pas là on est aussi suspecté
d'être toujours deux côtés de marc fait
maintenant je suis tellement ravie
qu'ils soient là on est là en même temps
donc voila c'était une petite 10 me par
rapport à ce qui s'était passé millions
merci c'est toujours bien surtout quand
même bien eu et c'est fou soit 2,3 de
trucs à alors c'est sûr qu'à l'est où il
fera demain allez pas là il fera demain
il faudra la garde et on verra qu'il a
dit ça à isabella le boulard depuis
qu'elle a animée tpm p ah tiens dix
jours je n'étais pas là le jour de
kippour
alors ça c'est pas moi mais je regrette
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que vous êtes d'accord vous
avec cette affirmation pas dit la vérité
à la changer complètement et non logés à
puch rené qui compte éventuellement nous
on existe mais là elles répondent plus
au téléphone bien sûr qu'elle agirait
l'étude de maître avec
vous l'avez ressenti comme ça c'est à
dire quand même un dîner ensemble tous
les mercredis soirs depuis qu'elle
animait tpe ne dîne plus battu malines
et demain
[Applaudissements]